The Joe Rogan experience,
what's hard for people to grasp is that you don't know what's next.
It's hard,
it's scary.
It freaks people out so they seek,
seek help with pills and booze,
bullshit and bad relationships and drama at work and all this nonsense that you
just filling up your stupid head with just to distract yourself from this
ultimate fascinating existence that we find ourselves in where we see we have no
idea what's coming next.
We don't know what's going on right now anywhere except what's right in front of
us and even then the wheels of perception,
they,
they eat ebb and flow depending on what chemicals even deuced into your body or
not.
He smoked a joint or ate a mushroom or you know,
there's a lot going on here.
It's not just as simple as this flat consciousness that we all agree upon
because I'm not entirely sure that other people have the same experience that I
do.
When I look at like some country music and I look at some TV shows and I look at
some.
I shouldn't even say country music,
a lot of pop music.
I actually probably more country music now than even like hot music,
expensive,
good times in the country,
but I'm a big dwight Yoakam fan.
I like my dog's named Johnny cash.
I like some country music,
but there's some really stupid shit out there.
Why is it?
Is it because they're dumber than me or are they seeing a different reality is
reality?
Just like your nose.
Your nose is a nose.
My nose,
his nose,
but if my nose was on your face,
I'd be like,
what do you do different?
You did something different and if you put your nose on my face,
you'd be like,
do some gum on your nose.
Looks different or something.
It would be.
We both have a notes.
It's very recognizable.
Neither one are distinct.
There's nothing.
You know,
W,
w we don't flatten.
Boxers,
noses or anything.
They're both pretty normal,
but I know my nose and I know your nose.
Your nose isn't my nose.
How do I know the test?
Not like reality.
That reality.
Like what?
What other people see?
They're seeing it through a filter that makes things that suck come in at,
come out there,
but a better shape.
They have it as a better smell to it.
Things that seemed stupid to you,
to them.
It all just fits right into this neuron and this,
this,
uh,
ability to interact with light,
accepts this shape better than that shape for some strange with orange has
always been my favorite color.
Or are you seeing the same color I am because aren't stupid?
How do you like orange?
Want an orange car?
You fucking Weirdo.
But you know what I mean?
It's like,
why would you like orange?
Is it a,
is it,
is it a taste thing or is it a taste thing and your world is different than
mine?
I think what you're mentioning is really one of the key lessons.
What I mentioned it his pot smoking nonsense
when I was on that,
when I did my,
my last Iowasca trip in Peru and I had the vision of the ego and that was the
secret that he basically gave me his up flying along with this condor eagle.
And the Eagle says to me,
you know,
you want to know how to see better.
You see through everybody else's eyes and the there was that everybody has their
own perception and to really understand what you're going through,
what they're going through and seeing.
You have to see what they see through their lens of perception.
And if you can do that,
you know all a lot of this hate and a lot of this anger goes away.
What you feel instead can be maybe pity I feel bad for this human look at the
way the world appears to them.
Look at the way you know that person is so quick to anger,
so quick to hate when really they could look at the same situation with love and
feel happiness.
And so it shifts your,
your kind of opinion on things,
but no doubt about it.
We look at things a different way and the recent studies on epigenetics will
show that you know things.
You can change the way things appear,
probably not only on a mental level,
but probably a genetic level based on your epigenetic manipulation of belief in
what you see and I think,
you know,
Bruce Lipton's doing a lot of good research in that and that's a really exciting
field,
but you know,
just because you have a certain lenses of perception doesn't mean that that
can't change with your choices and with your belief.
Yeah,
and that,
that change would help you.
We want to,
we want to hang on to the way we are so badly because we don't want to admit
that we were ever wrong.
If we met wherever wrong,
then we have this reevaluation of the value of self because the value of self is
very important and one of the important things a lot of people have at the
right,
they want to be right.
Like a lot of times you get in an argument with someone and at a certain point
and that you're like,
why are we even.
Why am I upset about this?
Like I have nothing to do with this lizard that lives in fucking the Komodo
islands.
I have nothing to do with them,
but you're insisting that it lives all over the place and I'm telling you it
only lives there and it's fucking zoos and like,
why is this even?
Why is this upsetting?
What is it about this?
What's really going on here?
People,
we develop patterns
and attachments.
Attachments to your attached to the persona of the guy who's right about random
facts,
you know,
so when you're attached to that and it gets challenged,
you identify with it.
That's part of you.
So it's actually threatening a piece of view which triggers the kind of fear
mechanism.
It's fascinating when you talk to someone in you.
I'm mean I,
I would never say that I'm absolutely free of that.
I'm not free of any human emotion,
but I'm,
I'm pretty good at controlling that impulse and I'm also pretty good at not
being attached to ideas until I've like really extremely vetted the mount and
also vetted out the opposing idea.
But I've had conversations with people where they'll say something and be like,
I had a conversation with this kid where he was talking about a psychedelic
mushrooms and he disagreed that he was like very adamant,
very smart kid,
very young,
probably like maybe 20.
And he was talking to me about how,
you know,
I disagree with Terence Mckenna's stoned mushroom theory.
He goes,
I think it's too simplistic.
And it,
it ignores the fact that there's so many different strange things that are uber
complex all throughout the universe.
You know,
why,
why should we assume that human beings got this way because of one compound?
And I was like,
you're right,
the fuck do I know I don't know nothing about.
And he was like,
he goes,
oh,
okay.
I can respect that.
I go,
yeah,
I mean,
what did I do?
The research am.
I don't know.
I think it's a good idea.
I think the idea is sound because I think that chimps obviously they think and
mushrooms make me think in a completely unique way.
And I think that if a chimp ate mushrooms,
it'll probably affect the way he thinks.
I mean,
it just seems to make sense.
No doubt.
I mean,
we can see it.
you look at,
you look at the pictures of the dolphins who are just doing that fucking the
puffer fish toxin.
They're going to the surface and looking at their reflection at that,
at that point.
That has to be changing.
Some of the usual usual pattern is probably fine.
Fresh fine fish,
let's find fish.
Fuck,
let's talk.
That's fine.
And then all of a sudden they stop all that and it quiets and they say,
wow,
look at me.
I'm a fucking dolphin.
And then it's a different pathway that opens up and that's what happened in
these monkeys to at a certain point,
irb humanoids or whatever,
what stage they were.
On a certain point,
they're like,
Woo.
Yeah.